excuse me i like your jacket internet
glass part i like your jacket and all
the blingings
wow thank you it's snazzy i the question
is did you do it yourself my mom
actually did she did yeah she's great
she's so awesome she's so cool she's so
great and mother's day is coming up i
know
she's great she is super awesome okay
this is your first time judging so you
think you can dance right
what type of judge are you gonna be
listen i think i'm the honest one i
think i just like because in real life
too i just say it how it is you know and
that's that's how i feel like i i'm a
judge
like i'm just so honest yeah what
happens if you absolutely hate something
well then i'd say that
you're just gonna say like i hate it
i'll beat around the bush a little bit
more than that
um but i i will get my point across and
i'm like listen this it just is it is it
my favorite thing that i've seen today
okay okay i'm just i'm trying to get a
sense of what type of
hair um so what type of dance moves are
you expecting to see what is something
that you're really looking forward to
because you are
incredible performer so what's going to
really wow you truthfully i think
everyone is going to get so creative
because you know we've had these few
years in lockdown where these dancers
have almost trained themselves in a way
you know in their living room so it's
going to be fun to see what they bring
to the table yeah
it's been three years since so you think
you can dance i'm assuming you're a fan
of course but what was your reaction
having come back after three years oh my
gosh i i mean just hearing that the show
was coming back i i got so excited about
it because it's just such a show
for the dancers you know what i mean for
the dancers to be on for the dancers to
watch and it just makes me so happy that
it's back yeah do you have a favorite
dance move on tick tock matthew said
he's not on tick tock it's grandpa what
is literally a grandpa i love him to
death but he's a grandpa um okay
favorite dance move on tic tac yeah you
know what one i like i like um
[Music]
okay five stars how do we do it two
thumbs is it two thumbs i don't remember
two thousand what's two thumbs for your
performance oh we can do two thumbs up
we can go tens we can go yes
all the things all the things it's all
the things it was so nice to talk to you
jojo thank you i'm excited to see you be
mean
man you're not both
you